[MUSIC PLAYING]
CALVIN FRENCH-OWEN:
Welcome, everyone.
I'm Calvin French-Owen, CTO
and co-founder of Segment.
And today I'd like to
share a few of the things
that we've been
up to at Segment.
Now I'd like to start
off by highlighting
the elephant in the room.
Today you're making
a hard choice.
You have to pick between
the three big cloud
providers in terms
of choosing where
to build your infrastructure.
You could pick Amazon, thought
to be the market leader.
You could pick Microsoft,
thought to have the best
enterprise solutions.
Or you could pick--
sorry.
You could pick Google, thought
to have the best technology.
Now you know that when
you make that choice
you're probably
going to be locked
in by some amount
of switching cost,
and more likely than not maybe
a one to three year commitment.
And moreover, it's going to have
lasting ramifications on things
like the cost of your
infrastructure, maybe
your performance that
you're able to get.
Maybe it's even your ability
to deliver a final product
on time and under budget.
Now at Segment, this was the
position we found ourselves
in about a year and a half ago.
We were trying to deliver
a new product, Personas.
And we kept hitting the
limits of what the Amazon
infrastructure could do for us.
So we started turning our
attention to other options
out on the table.
And the ones we found
were on Google Cloud.
In particular
using two products,
BigQuery and Bigtable,
allowed us to build out
our new product, Personas,
and deliver it to our users
and create millions of dollars
of revenue in a single year.
Today I'd like to
lead you on a journey
through Personas, its
underlying architecture,
and how we've leveraged
these two different cloud
products to deliver a
fully finished product.
I'm hoping that you can
take some of the lessons
away and apply them to
your own infrastructure
when it comes to building
on top of Google Cloud.
So let's dive in.
As part of today's
roadmap, I'd like
to start out with a
little bit of background.
What is Segment?
How does it work?
Then we'll transition to the
architecture of Persona itself,
how it's built,
and what use case
it's designed to address, before
diving in deep to understand
how it's built on top of
both BigQuery and Bigtable.
Finally, we'll revisit
some of those hard choices
that we've had to make in
production ourselves, and talk
about some of the
trade-offs that we see now
and going forward.
So a bit of background--
what is Segment?
What's the scale that
we're seeing today?
For those of you who
might not be familiar,
Segment gives you a
single API to collect data
about your users.
These might be things like users
loading pages on your website.
Maybe it's signing up
via your mobile app.
Maybe it's completing orders
on your online checkout.
Whatever it is, your users are
doing things with your app,
and you want to
know who they are
and why they're doing the
things that they're doing.
Concretely, what
that looks like is
that Segment gives
you the set of sources
that you see on the left.
These are places
where your data lives,
whether it's your mobile app,
website, or maybe a source
like Stripe or Zendesk.
We will take that data
into one consistent place
and then get it into hundreds
of different SaaS tools
that you might be using
over on the right.
These could be data warehouses
like Redshift or BigQuery.
Maybe it's an email tool
like Customer.io or Zendesk.
Or maybe it's an analytics
tool like Google Analytics
or Mixpanel.
Whatever it is, Segment helps
you get that single source
of truth about
your data into all
of those different destinations.
Now by the numbers,
this has taken us
to some interesting places.
Today we collect data for
19,000 users every single month.
And in terms of our
intake, we process
about 300 billion events
every single month, as well.
That translates to
roughly 450 billion
outbound API calls that
we're making, and processing
terabytes of data per day.
Now to date, all
this infrastructure
has run on Amazon.
It's running in Amazon's
compute environment,
and we're processing
all of that data using
ECS and a fleet of
16,000 containers.
And under the hood, it
looks something a little bit
like this.
We have our API
at the front door,
which is ingesting events.
It's then publishing
those to Kafka,
which we use as our
primary message bus,
where we're collecting all
these different sorts of events.
And then from there
we have a consumer
who's reading each message,
reading from a database,
and figuring out where
that data should be sent,
and then deciding to send that
data to certain destinations.
Maybe this event is bound
for Google Analytics.
This other one is
built for Salesforce.
Another one is even
sent to Mixpanel.
And maybe we have
one which is supposed
to go to all of the above.
Now there's a
really big advantage
of this system in the way
that we've architected it.
And that's that it's stateless.
If we want to add more
capacity to the system,
it gives us more throughput.
We can simply just double the
amount of collection points,
the amount of Kafka brokers,
the amount of consumers.
And really the only shared
thing here is our database.
But maybe we can get
past that with some read
replicas and some caching.
In our case, it's really easy
to scale out more capacity
as our load doubles,
triples, 10x's or 50x's.
It kind of doesn't matter.
But in 2018, our product
team started giving us
a new set of requirements.
In particular, it was to
launch this new product called
Personas.
The idea was a take
Segment from this place
which simply streamed
individual events around,
where each event
maybe doesn't have
any correlation to the
others, to actually creating
the idea of a user profile,
something that's a little more
holistic who tells you what the
user is and what they're doing.
Hopefully it should
tell you a little bit
about who they are,
where they've been,
and allow you to query
that in real time.
As you might guess, this use
case is decidedly stateful.
We can't any longer just add
nodes to our infrastructure
and expect them all to
fan out and kind of work
in this magical way.
Instead, now we actually have to
pull our data together and put
it into one spot, so
that if we query it
we get a both consistent
and available answer.
To give you a better sense
of what these staple use
cases look like, let me walk
you through the three use
cases of Personas.
The first one is what
we call the profile API.
The general idea
here is that we have
some set of information
about the user, who they are,
what they've done.
And we want to be able
to pull that information
programmatically.
Now there's two use cases
which we found this for.
The biggest one is for building
personalization systems
in your web app.
Let's say you're
running an online store.
You sell all different
types of pants--
men's pants, women's
pants, kid's pants.
But you've seen a user come
back in the past 10 times
in the last month, and they've
only looked at men's pants.
Maybe you should change
up your home page.
Make it guide them a little
bit towards finding only men's
pants, so they don't have to
click around and potentially
abandon your entire
checkout flow.
The second use case,
after the profile
API for personalization, is
around identity resolution.
As I said before,
we're collecting data
from many different places.
Maybe it's your web app.
Maybe it's your mobile app.
Maybe it's another source
like Zendesk or Stripe.
Each of those users may
get a different identity.
Maybe it's their email.
Maybe it's the ID that you
have in your user database.
Or maybe it's something else,
like a Stripe customer ID.
We want to be able to take
those different individual
identifiers and unify
them, so that if you
want to query for a
user it doesn't matter
if they're Calvin at Segment or
if they're XYZ123, or Stripe,
some other CUS_whatever.
We want to be able to
say, here's Calvin.
Here's my user.
And finally, the third use
case after the profile API
and identity resolution
is audience computation.
Now for those of you who
might not be familiar--
I certainly wasn't when
we first started Segment.
An audience is just
a group of people
who meet certain criteria.
You want to be able to
specify certain rules to say,
hey, which of my users
have visited three times
in the past month, started
a checkout flow last week,
but then never completed it?
Personas gives you this ability
to create those arbitrary
rules, and then find
that list of users.
So that's Personas.
You query users in real
time via the profile API,
match them by identity,
and then create
audiences of users, as well.
Let's take a look at how it's
architected under the hood.
Now I wanted to start
by first talking
about lambda architectures.
And don't worry, I'm at
the right conference.
This is a different type
of lambda architecture
than the serverless one
you might be hearing about.
Now this lambda
architecture actually comes
from this guy, Nathan
Marz, who is at Twitter.
And he kept coming up
with these concepts
of how he could process lots
and lots of data in real time.
And he wanted to
ensure that he could
crunch both large amounts
of data, potentially
terabytes or
petabytes, but also get
a good real-time view of
individual parts of analysis
that he is running.
And so he came up with the
system that you see behind me.
The general idea is
that new data comes in
via single source, but
then it's written twice.
First, it's written
to a batch layer,
some sort of job that's
running maybe hourly or daily,
is doing big roll ups and
aggregations of a bunch
of different pieces of data.
From there, he also writes data
to what he calls a speed layer.
You could think of this as
being something like Kafka,
or the queue that we've
been keeping track of.
This effectively has the diff
of whatever the batch layer has.
Then, at query time,
you effectively
want to pull those
two pieces together.
You can grab your big
aggregation that you have,
as well as your little
real-time updates
that you've been making.
Now if you look at this, we have
a few different use cases here.
We have batch computations.
We have speed to get us the
best of both worlds in terms
of aggregation and in
terms of real-time updates.
It actually doesn't look
that different from what
we want on Personas.
We want to be able to query
our profiles in real time
and match users by identity.
And we want those actions to
happen incredibly quickly,
ideally under a second.
But we also want to
create audiences of users.
And this is where we
scan terabytes of data.
And maybe it's OK if it
takes a few minutes or maybe
even an hour to come back.
Now you might be
thinking, well, it
sounds like you have
different pipelines
with different requirements.
Why not use different
data stores?
And that's exactly what we did.
We effectively have our
single message bus in Kafka,
then publishing
to Cloud Pub/Sub,
and from there we have two
separate sets of workers
who are writing the data twice.
One set of workers is writing
that data into BigQuery
to do batch processing,
to create those audiences.
The second set of workers
are writing into Bigtable
to give us real-time
results and updates.
I'm going to start on the
left hand side of this diagram
before moving into the
right to really explore
some of these use cases.
Now for those of you
who aren't familiar,
Kafka and Pub/Sub both are this
kind of idea of a message bus.
Each one can take
individual messages
and then replicate
them for delivery.
To give you a better sense of
what Segment messages actually
look like, I've included an
example over here on the right.
Segment messages
involve tracking things
like page views,
user events, maybe
it's completed order
events, whatever it is.
Here, I just took an
example from my blog.
Typically these are
semi-structured JSON.
So Segment, as part
of our API spec,
we specify that there are a few
top level fields that you need.
These will be things like the
user ID, the event name, maybe
a timestamp to let us know
when the event happened.
But the rest is all filled
in by our customers,
depending on what's
important to them.
So, for example, here can see
that there are a few custom
properties.
It's the name of the article.
Maybe it's the referrer.
If you're running a
music app, maybe it's
something like the song
title or the artist.
Whatever it is, we can't really
anticipate it ahead of time.
It's just our users
sending it into our API.
So that's a key part of our
data processing pipeline.
And typically, these
messages run to about 1
kilobyte in terms of average,
though they may span up
to 32 kilobytes depending
on how much stuff is just
packed into that message.
To give you a sense of what this
actually looks like from a code
perspective, I have included
basically a light version
of the code that
takes data from Kafka
and publishes it into Pub/Sub.
Effectively, we iterate over
a range of messages here.
We create a payload of
them, tagging each message
with its type and collection,
basically what sort of thing
it is, whether it's a user,
product, or an account.
We pack that all into JSON, and
then we compress it via Snappy.
And then we ship
it off the Pub/Sub.
And from there we're
trying to analyze
these hundreds of thousands
of 1 kilobyte messages, where
for one branch we
send it into our batch
commutations in BigQuery,
and for the second branch
we send into the real-time
computations in Bigtable.
So let's dive into
each of those, BigQuery
and Cloud Bigtable.
For each one, I'd like
to compare them first
on the use case that
we're trying to achieve.
Second, the underlying
architecture
pulled, from the best
of my understanding,
from white papers and papers
that are published externally
by Google.
Third, we'll talk about their
data model, what it actually
looks like to store Segment
data in these systems.
And then fourth, we'll
discuss the query patterns,
how we're actually using
this in production.
So let's revisit this use case.
On the top here,
we have the worker,
which is running and
loading data into BigQuery.
And because this is a
batch job we can run it,
let's say, every 15 minutes
or kind of whatever schedule
we want.
Separately, we're running
and then computing
this data via the
compute service, which
is effectively just running a
cron job to calculate audiences
for our users every
so many minutes.
And again, we want
to find users who
meet arbitrary criteria here.
We don't know what those
criteria are ahead of time.
It's up to our users
to specify them.
We have terabytes of data
sitting in the system,
and we need to get responses
within a few minutes.
But it doesn't
have to be seconds,
milliseconds, nanoseconds.
We rarely care about all of the
columns, which is pretty key.
Oftentimes, we'll be
only trying to say, hey,
who are users who have done
event X more than Y times,
or maybe find the only
users in San Francisco.
In this case, we're picking one
tiny part of our information
and then extracting
a list of user IDs.
And again, real-time reads
are not a big deal here.
We need maybe only tens
of concurrent queries
to satisfy our user base.
And so as long as we're able
to get that, we're good.
So let's look at what BigQuery
looks like under the hood.
Now I'm going to do a
quick history lesson here.
Internally at Google,
there have been
a number of systems
for crunching
large amounts of data.
And back in 2004, kind of
the seminal paper on this
was called MapReduce.
And at the time, Google was
trying to compute basically
the entire index of the web.
Sounds like a small goal, right?
And so with MapReduce
they said, hey,
we want to build a
crawl the entire web.
Then we want to be able to
figure out page rank for each
of these pages.
We want to be able to say which
pages are those popular based
upon which pages
then link to them.
And so MapReduce was
this internal system
that Google had where
as the programmer,
you needed to write
two functions.
You need to write a map
function and a reduce function.
And as long as you
specified those two things
and then passed
in your data set,
you'll be able to
get your results back
within maybe hours or
maybe the next day.
But it was the best
thing that they
had for literally web scale data
at the time, so they used it.
And they were able to parse
a lot of free form text.
But then in 2010 a new paper
came out called Dremel.
And this is really the
basis for BigQuery.
Now in the paper they say
that this has actually
been put around since 2006.
But Dremel was designed to solve
a different set of problems
than MapReduce.
In particular, it was designed
for interactive analysis.
Now you can think
of Dremel as sort
of being the internal
version of BigQuery.
But in terms of
how they're set up,
my understanding is that
they're roughly the same.
For BigQuery and Dremel, that
interactive piece is key.
Now, instead of
being an analyst who
had to wait hours
or maybe overnight
to get back your
results, you just
get them within a few minutes.
So if you were
exploring your data,
it could actually give
you a really good sense
of what was in it.
The other big advantage
of Dremel and BigQuery
was that it used SQL
rather than programming.
Before, you might end up writing
a big MapReduce job saying,
yes, this looks great.
And then you ship it off
to whatever your MapReduce,
or maybe externally a
Hadoop cluster looks like.
And then when you come
back, it turns out
some part of your
program had errored,
which means that you have to
run the entire thing again.
Because BigQuery
and Dremel use SQL,
it meant that it was accessible
to your average analyst
and could get you back data as
well as errors in a very, very
quick timescale.
Additionally, it uses
nested structured data,
which I'll talk about
a little bit more here,
rather than the free form
text that MapReduce just
says, OK, you have some sort
of input of bytes and output.
In particular, I'd like to
highlight four good ideas that
are all pulled from the
Dremel and BigQuery paper.
And these are all
ideas that we've
used to successfully
scan terabytes
of data within a few minutes.
The first idea is
being column-oriented.
And let me talk a more
about what this means.
Suppose we want to
build a database.
We want to create something
where I can add data to it.
I can query it.
And I know that that write data
is somehow written durably.
How might we do it?
Well, let's assume we're doing
the dead simple thing here.
And I'm just adding
to a flat file,
where each row involves
a new row in my database,
or a new record.
Maybe first I have the name
of the engineer on my team.
Maybe I have their job position.
Maybe I have how
many contributions
they've had in the last year.
And then maybe I
have their location.
And on the face of
this, this kind of looks
like a standard database.
Right?
It's like, if I want more rows.
I can add them to the end.
If I update, I could
update in place
or I could potentially add
to the end and merge later.
It seems like it does what
I want, just as a flat file.
But now let's get back
to our problem statement.
What if my database
has billions of rows
and I only need one of them?
What if I only need the
location data, for example?
Remember, we want to be
able to scan all this data
incredibly quickly.
Well, the good idea
that BigQuery had is,
hey, let's store
columns, not rows.
If we look back at my super
simple database example
here, instead of
storing a single file
with each row
indicating a record,
let's instead split them up.
Let's keep one file
for each column.
Then if I want to grab the
location itself, it's easy.
I just read the location file.
And now I don't have
to parse through all
of this unnecessary data that
maybe I don't care about,
for things like the
person's name or their role
or how many contributions
they've had.
And I don't have to
split those commas,
do all that CSV processing.
Instead, I just get what I want.
And under the hood, it turns
out that BigQuery and Dremel
do the same exact thing.
Instead of storing rows as
records or records as rows,
rather, they keep columns which
individual nodes can store.
So if you only need
to grab one thing,
you just scan super quickly and
then you get your result back.
The second good idea
is actually related
to being column-oriented,
and that's using compression.
As you might have
noticed, if I have
all of these columns on disk--
San Francisco, San Francisco,
Tokyo, San Francisco,
San Francisco--
we have a lot of
repeated data here.
And in particular, if I need
to scan all that data on disk
or if it's from a
backing data file storer,
I need to do a lot of
network transfer costs,
as well as just raw
seeking of the data itself.
So instead we can compress
it by using something
like run-length encoding.
The general idea here
is that, let's say
I have 200 entries
which all have
San Francisco as the entry.
I can now encode them
and say San Francisco 200
before reading the next
column, which maybe is Tokyo 1.
And then maybe I have
another San Francisco 100.
In practice, when I have a
really, really big data set,
this makes scanning it and
parsing it much, much quicker.
So we have column-oriented
and compression.
The third idea that
I'd like to touch on
is an efficient nested encoding.
And I'll get back to why this
is important in a few minutes.
But to give you a
sense of what exactly
this is, BigQuery gives
you the ability to specify
what your data looks like.
Here it's represented
as protobufs,
which is a technology that we
also use internally at Segment.
Instead of storing
all of that data
and serialized it as JSON
or some other format,
BigQuery actually keeps
this idea of a field column
and a depth column,
which will let
you know if you're parsing
that data whether you're still
in the same field or not.
And honestly, this
goes into more depth
than I'm able to share
during this quick talk.
But to give you
an example, here's
what happens when you
select all of your fields.
BigQuery will actually generate
a finite state machine,
which figures out depending
on what that record field
and depth field are, how it
should traverse your document.
And then from there,
it actually pulls apart
that finite state
machine to parse it
into its own structs or
protobufs, or whatever it is.
This makes sure that if you're
parsing billions of records
you can do it extremely
quickly, without having
a lot of overhead of
trying to figure out
sizing and allocations
for those results.
So we had a bunch of
tactics for making
scanning on an individual
machine much quicker.
The last one I'd like to share
is this idea of adding servers
to increase efficiency.
Obviously, if we're querying
these terabyte data sets
on Google Cloud hardware,
it's much different
than if those data sets are
just running on my laptop
within my own little database.
Now BigQuery makes
use of this same idea.
Effectively if you're a
client, you take data--
or first you hit the root server
and you submit your query.
And then there's a set of
intermediate servers, which
are basically figuring
out how to fan out
that query to individual leaf
nodes, where each of those leaf
nodes then does only a
small subset of the work
and passes back the results.
To get an example of
what this looks like,
let's say you're
querying the root node.
And maybe for this example
you have just one single layer
in our tree.
If we get our responses
back, that root node actually
has to merge all of our
data, which could potentially
be a lot.
Instead, as is
discussed in the paper
and as this technique that's
used behind the hood, what
ends up happening is there are
different layers, which each
individually split up the work.
So now if we issue
a query, there
are a bunch of intermediate
mergers that happen.
So each node has to deal with
much, much smaller data set.
The great thing here is that
more servers effectively
means more distributed work.
And the fact that it's running
in this giant multi-tenant
system that's been in place at
Google for the past 10 years
means that we have a pretty good
confidence that those servers
are doing a lot of
shared computation
and getting good utilization.
So those are BigQuery's
four good ideas--
being column oriented,
compressing data
so it's read quickly
from a single node,
using a fast nested data
encoding, which also supports
arrays and nested objects,
and distributing the work,
especially by separating
data and compute.
Let's look at how that data
model now maps into Personas,
and how nuts to bolts
we're using BigQuery.
Remember, as I said before,
we want to allow users
to create custom audiences.
These are just groups of users
who meet certain criteria.
We effectively want
to take this criteria
and turn it into,
more or less, a SQL
query with custom parameters.
But how we do this could
be difficult. Right?
It's like we have this
kind of a custom UI.
And if we add new
features to it,
we don't want to then have to
be building a bunch of stuff
on the back end to translate it.
So what we do is we convert
it to an intermediate format.
We convert it into JSON as part
of an abstract syntax tree.
And then from there we actually
convert that AST into raw SQL.
It's all machine
generated, but to our user
it gives them this
nice interface
that meets them on their
level, while, for us, it
gives us the power
and flexibility of SQL
on the back end.
In terms of how we're
actually storing this data,
we keep a data set per customer
to provide isolation and better
monitoring across them.
And then we keep a table per
each collection and event.
Remember, a collection is
just the type of thing,
whether it's a user,
account, or product.
Additionally, we keep tables for
things like traits, identity,
and merging.
And in particular, I want
to call your attention
to this set of external IDs.
This is the nested, repeated
format that BigQuery allows.
And it's one that you won't
find in a lot of other data
warehouses or big data stores.
The fact that this allows us to
specify multiple external IDs,
whether it's an email or
whether it's a database ID
or whether it's a
Stripe ID, means
that if we want to query for
any one of those, we can.
And we can be sure that it's
quickly findable and indexed,
and we're not spending a
bunch of time parsing JSON
or trying to dig
into these objects.
It's right there as
a top level field.
Additionally, we
end up exploding
all of these properties
that the user passes in.
In our V1, we actually stored
these specifically as JSON,
and kind of in its own field.
But what we found
is that we actually
got much better performance
by exploding them out, doing
the alterations of the table
when we're uploading that data,
and making sure that
we're able to query it
quickly and efficiently.
So let's look at
the query patterns.
How is this being
used in production?
Remember, this is the job
of the compute service.
The compute service is sending
data, or sending queries
across a handful at a time.
And it's trying to run
those as an aggregate,
as sort of a cron job.
Maybe every few minutes
it's saying, OK,
what's new with this
audience for customer A?
What's new with this
audience for customer B?
audience for customer C?
What this looks like
under the hood--
and I grabbed a few queries
from our production account--
is that this is creating
these tens of queries
per second, which honestly
looks like garbage.
And it's because it's
all machine generated.
At the end of the day,
we don't care about what
these queries look like.
We only care that
our customers are
able to have flexibility
when it comes to querying
those different data sets.
And in terms of
actual query times,
we see good
performance, as well.
We're able to query gigabytes
or terabytes in a matter
of seconds or minutes.
Additionally, this
gives our users
the ability to preview
particular users who
might fall into this
audience, because they're
able to interactively query.
So they can check and see,
hey, did the audience I built
actually work out properly.
And we also give them insights
about potentially overlapping
audiences that they might have,
areas where user IDs might also
fall into this audience.
Looking at our [? numbers ?]
in production by today,
we're currently scanning about
2 gigabytes every single second,
which corresponds to
about 170 terabytes a day.
And we're using about 800 slots.
So that roughly wraps
up our BigQuery section.
We run our batch
computations here
for tens of concurrent queries.
We're partitioning
it by customer,
so we get good visibility
and isolation across them.
And we end up keeping
these repeated
arrays of external
IDs, so that if we
want to query by a
particular ID, we can.
Let's shift gears to the speed
side of the equation now.
Remember, we want to be able
to query for this profile API.
In this case, we can't get data
that's minutes or hours old.
Right?
But we also don't care
about querying for data
across all of our users.
Instead, we want to get data in
real time for the specific user
when they're on the web page.
And that takes this bottom
path, the speed layer.
The use cases here
are much different.
Instead of having to crunch
our gigabytes or terabytes
worth of data across
all users, now we're
simply looking at kilobytes
to megabytes of data.
We want to primarily
index it based upon user,
and then maybe to a
second extent, time.
And we need a high
read and write rate.
We're potentially doing tens of
thousands of queries per second
here.
And again, data should be
reflected in real time.
We want this to happen in
under 300 to 500 milliseconds.
Now, it's interesting when I
was reading the Bigtable paper,
that this is actually
not that new of an idea.
It turns out Google
Analytics keeps
their raw [? Quick ?] Table
in the same sort of format.
And so in terms of building
out Bigtable for ourselves,
we figured, hey, this
actually makes a lot of sense.
We just have to figure out how
to make it work with Segment.
And to give you an idea, let's
now dig into the Bigtable
architecture.
So Bigtable, the paper,
was released in 2006.
And it talks about a
distributed storage
system for structured data.
Effectively, you
can think about it
as kind of a big key
value store, where all
the keys themselves are sorted.
So if you want to get
little bits of data
or maybe a range of keys,
you're able to do it.
Under the hood it looks
something like this.
We typically have a client,
which is making queries
to individual Bigtable nodes.
Each of those Bigtable nodes
are keeping an in-memory data
structure that they
call a mem table, what
you think of as a sort of
list of keys and values
that are append only,
that then it also backs
on associated Google
file system tablets.
These are the
storage layer where
we're sure that we're
persisting the data to make sure
that in case there's some sort
of crash or an [INAUDIBLE]
away, that that data
is still replicated
and is still durable.
Here's what happens
when we issue a write.
First, that write gets
directed to the right Bigtable
node via some sort
of master lookup
table, kind of like Chubby,
or another lock service.
And then it actually gets
appended to the in-memory data
structure on the node itself,
before being backed or appended
to the backing storage, as well.
What this means is that
writes are really fast.
They end up being
these fast appends that
don't require a lot
of locking, and you
can write extremely quickly.
But then they're mirrored
by the underlying storage
infrastructure.
Reads, similarly
can also be fast.
Let's say we want
to read a new key.
If it's in our in-memory
data structure, which
we can filter for based
upon using a Blum filter,
we can probably still detect
that it's there and then run
a look up in memory to get a
result that's really quick.
If that's the case, then we pass
back the value from that node
and we get a very
quick read, especially
if the locality is good.
If we've written
the value recently,
then chances are it's
probably still in memory.
If not, we actually fetch that
offset from the backing storage
hardware.
And then we can get it back.
Now in this case, reads
first cache and then
they get merged together.
So our write path is super
fast, but our read path
is pretty quick, too.
Because it's coming from memory
most of the time, and then
it's just merging whatever
the diffs are together.
You might be
thinking, though, what
about if there's an
underlying failure.
What if one of these
nodes goes down?
Well, in that case,
we're OK, too.
Let's say we have the
same read path, which
is fetching data from
our backing storage,
and this node dies.
Well, because we've
separated compute
from the underlying
storage, we're
able now just to move those
portions onto a new Bigtable
node, and claim that
it now has ownership.
And now we're able to just
read that same data, which
goes to the same underlying
storage, and get it back.
And those are the things that
make Bigtable work really
well for our use case.
It's multi-tenant.
It's row-oriented.
It uses a log
structure merge tree
under the hood to ensure that
there's fast reads and writes.
It has immutable
in-memory caching.
And it does a lot
of different tricks
to make sure that in
individual node level
it's saving us both
on reads and writes.
Now let's talk about how
it comes to our data model,
how Segment fits into here.
Remember I said
before that this is
used to query data
about individual users.
So we actually keep separate
data tables for each data type.
We have one for records,
letting us know who the user is.
We have one for
properties, giving us
various traits about them.
And we have one for
events, actually storing
raw event payloads if we
want to pass those back
to the front end.
The keys are
typically ID and time
ordered so that we're able
to get a range, let's say,
give me the events that happened
in the past five minutes.
And the values are
Snappy encoded,
so that if we want
to pull them we can
do so quickly and efficiently.
And in particular when
we stitch these together,
we keep different
tables for different
read and write profiles.
So we'll actually
use different ones,
depending on what sort of
query patterns we have.
I'd like to wrap up by sharing
a little bit about how this
has gone for us in production.
In production today
with Cloud Bigtable,
we're currently writing
55,000 rows per second,
and reading a little
north of 3x that.
We're storing 10 terabytes
of data in the system.
And it's all being powered
by 16 different nodes.
You can see here that
we're describing all of it
within Terraform.
So if we need to
make a change, we
can do so quickly and easily.
For BigQuery, we're running
hundreds of queries per minute.
This is a lot less than
the Bigtable throughput,
because it's not
designed to be real time.
It's only for a
small subset of users
creating aggregate
pieces of data
on top of their
individual user profiles.
Here we're scanning
gigabytes of data per minute.
And we're storing 500 terabytes
worth of data, overall.
But let's get back
to that hard choice.
If we're choosing
between different clouds,
I think BigQuery is just
straight up hard to compare.
There aren't many
other clouds out there
which offer the same sort
of multi-tenant, heavily
battle-tested infrastructure
that BigQuery does.
It's able to give you
large amounts of data
querying in incredibly
quick query times.
And to my knowledge, there isn't
anything out there, with maybe
of the possible
exception of Snowflake,
that even comes
close when it comes
to actually using this data.
But we will look at Bigtable,
there are actually a few more
alternatives out there,
which seem to exist.
You could use Dynamo.
You could host your own
sort of foundation DV
setup, kind of whatever it is.
There are a few different
places where Bigtable actually
really shines for us.
Now when we first started,
we ended up using Dynamo.
And we kept running into
problems that made it really,
really hard to work with,
particularly around scaling,
cost, and identifying hotkeys.
And for those of you
who are familiar,
remember each Bigtable node
hosts some subset of keys.
So if we have one user who
is recording a lot of data
all at once or one
particular key that
is sending hundreds of
thousands or tens of thousands
of writes per second, that
individual key gets really hot.
It ends up being accessed
far more than the rest.
And finding those
keys can be tricky.
Because typically
what will happen
is they'll bring down the
rest of your infrastructure
and just slow everything
down, and it's incredibly hard
to figure out what happened.
So when we're using Dynamo
we ended up actually
admitting metrics
around these hotkeys,
and then coming up with
a system to figure out
where this was happening.
But in Bigtable they
just gave it to us.
There's an out of
the box tool that
tells you what you're read
and write pattern looks like.
It tells you how the keys
that are being accessed.
And you can just go in and
click and figure out which
users are hurting you most.
And this system is honestly
invaluable for debugging,
because it
immediately highlights
where the problems are.
The second one is
mostly around cost.
At Segment, we have a
very write-heavy workload.
Most of the time we just
have all these events
that are coming in, and it's
honestly a little bit rarer
that we have users
who are querying
that data via our APIs.
As it turns out,
Bigtable is much better
at splitting this data
between compute and storage.
And what's more, unlike
some of the other solutions
out there where you may
be charged differently
for writes and
reads, for Bigtable
your charged the exact same.
You're just charged for a node.
And so if we want to be writing
more data than we're reading,
the cost profile actually
benefits us significantly,
because we're able to separate
that compute and storage
and just be charged for
the raw throughput, rather
than anything special about
our custom workload profile.
So in closing, I wanted to
leave you with a few thoughts.
This is Segment
Personas, powered
by Bigtable and BigQuery.
Bigtable helps us for
small random reads.
BigQuery is what we use
for the batch operations.
We're able to process
billions of events.
And we use a large,
multitenant architecture,
so that each customer's data
gets their own individual
tables and data
sets, but that we're
able to run the same compute
infrastructure everywhere.
This infrastructure gives us
favorable read and write costs,
and already we've
been able to generate
millions of dollars in
revenue from this new product.
Additionally, we have
the firm knowledge
that as we continue
to scale and grow,
many of these systems that we
have underlying will change.
But we know that under the
hood, both BigQuery and Bigtable
are able to scale out to levels
far beyond what we see today.
So if you're
considering building
your own infrastructure
upon them,
I'd highly recommend
investing in Google
for your different data stores.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]